- True Blood is halfway
through its final season,
and I'm really bummed
because where else
on HBO are you gonna be able
to see graphic violence and sex?
(audience whoops and cheers)
Here to, did you just cheer that
because I said violence and sex?
You didn't even hear any--
(audience cheers)
You're not even listening
to anything else
other than violence and sex.
(audience cheers)
Stop it!
I hate that I love you so much.
(audience laughs)
Here to help us take one
last bite out of True Blood
is one of the stars,
Kristin Bauer van Straten.
Kristin!
(pulsing groovy music)
(audience applauds and cheers)
- [Kristin] Hi.
- Welcome, nice to see you.
So good to see you.
- [Kristin] Yeah.
- What are your feelings now
that True Blood is wrapping up?
- Well, you know, seven
years I've been hanging out
with these people.
So I'm gonna miss my friends.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna miss the
camaraderie and the merkins.
Speaking of, you
know, vagina art.
(Chris and audience laugh)
- We're all wearing them
right now, by the way.
(Kristin, Chris,
and audience laugh)
It's not just your show.
(Chris and audience laugh)
- So, comedians, which of the
following True Blood items
got the most favorites
on deviantart.com?
So this is an
interesting, you know.
(Chris and audience laugh)
Yeah.
- It's Sookie with the Count.
That's the only vampire
she hasn't (bleep) yet.
(Kristin and audience laugh)
- [Chris] Wait,
wait, wait, what?
- Okay, so this is my maker.
(audience whoops)
- What's the last one?
- Oh, and this is a
Pam-inspired piece.
- Ah.
You got your little
cutie mark right there.
- Right?
- That's fantastic.
All right, so which one of
those got the most favorites?
(buzzer dings)
Scott Aukerman.
- I'm gonna say "A" just
'cause people would like
to hear him count
up to 67, ah ah ahh.
(audience cheers)
68, ah ah ahh.
- All right, let's find
out the actual answer is.
(game board chimes)
Yes, the Count.
(audience cheers)
Well done!
Please thank Kristin
for being here.
Catch her in the final
season of True Blood on HBO.
Thank you so much
for being here.
- Thank you.
- So good to see you.
- Congratulations.
Kristin Bauer van Straten!
(pulsing groovy music)
(audience applauds and cheers)